hello everybody my name is markiplier I
just woke up but it's time I've got to
get this in before I leave for Korea and
72 rivets in this room which can only
mean one thing I'm bored I know you hey
is anyone hurt down there I gotta go
after tonight we gotta go make sure
everyone's okay okay suddenly you're
looking at us now well you're gonna stay
here with the radio I'll go after them
what if something happens to you I'm a
big boy this is my mess and I'll clean
it up obvious to anybody with radio good
luck down there ah he's so nice he's
matured he's gonna save his sister I
thought Conrad was gonna be like a like
a big dumb doofy whoa
that's a shaky camera all right so
excuse me as I wake up so if my reaction
times are a little slow don't you worry
because I've turned on look guys look
guys look I just woke up my reaction
times my fingers aren't fingering at
their top speed it's at the end of the
game I cannot risk being stupid and it's
still good because at the bottom look
zoom licks Ian pressing the wrong button
will still fail the QuickTime event so I
still have to press the right button hey
wait why does this go somewhere which is
just not the secret way I never know
what the secret ways and what the not
secret way is what's the secret way then
then what was that what I hate yeah okay
good okay good if it was gonna be like
suddenly this was the path because
checking behind me it's done that in
this game before where I'm like I think
I'm checking the way it doesn't
automatically want me to go therefore
I'm getting the goods go get down I
can't go up wake up give me a jump scare
I need to wake up where's that old lady
you're still beautiful to me drop down
I think we're getting close to the
conclusion of this don't cut yourself
I'm ready bring it on bring it all on
bring wait my gamer senses are tingling
up a Starman what was behind me I asked
again nothing god damn it all of my
wasted talent here all of my incredible
instinct being thwarted
it doesn't look vaguely familiar from
where we were walk I'm awake now I'm
awake I've never been so awake in my
life
I'm away where did you come from big boy
God that'll wake you up and that's what
I need in the morning
better than a alarm clock a condom
jump-scare alright huh I don't know if
this is the secret way or not you see
okay you see how I can get confused by
this I'm thinking that this is oh wait
no hang on what's all this then
who the hell is that Cthulhu
what
who the hell what
okay so if someone's trying to hang
themselves they might slip off anyway or
if that's not someone trying to hang
them you know what I don't know what
that is but I'm thinking that this is
not the secret way okay I'm gonna go
back I'm gonna go back because that door
has my name on it
and I swear if that leads me down a path
that gets me nowhere or that continues
the game on I am going to be livid I'm
gonna be beyond livid I'm gonna be so
mad and I'm checking this because one
few thing I can check do all field
offices the scale of our search and
recovery missions across the area have
you so far results far greater than
expected unfortunately there's no
shortage of adult caskets if you locate
the remains of any missing persons to
the water purification plan you may have
to use a smaller cast against someone
and do what crush him into him that
doesn't make any sense at all
okay I'm gonna go back and check the
other door and it better just be cook
Leung key I'm lucky because if it's
clunky I open this place yeah well I'm
right there with you funky okay good
that's that's all I wanted to know
that's all I wanted to know because you
could see home a little hesitant to try
which door because there's no indication
of what's going to be a lock out and
what's going to be a oh we continue on
forever and then the story you'll just
miss out on some good [ __ ] that happened
over there no no that's not how I'm
gonna run this that's not how I'm gonna
run this at all oh no you can you can
you okay whatever man-- the directional
changes are just too much from my feeble
mind to take advantage of here we go
how the hell big is this place
how the hell big it was a nice ramp that
went down you didn't need to do that
alright we're frozen and we're not fro
something tells me this is the worst
place to be
[Applause]
cool out come on no one's gonna get hurt
Oh QuickTime event
all right I'm ready I'm ready all right
we'll go back up he's got a hammer we're
cool I thought a good idea
no no I wouldn't do that no please don't
even talk this out man we can bond over
how much we hate this boat so you think
that's the best solution here
oh good thing I remember what s was
I still got that in the window
I think I turned it off did I turn it
Hey
oh god oh god please stop messing with
me you have to change that ASD I don't
know what those are I just can't I just
can't hit the wrong button then where
did you come from B they just see you
see you see how I need this you see how
I need this okay cuz otherwise that
would have been my skull crashed open
hey not even like a hi what are you
doing here W okay I got this uh cut
that's good I'm gonna nail that nail
that guy's I'm nailing it I'm nailing it
guys I'm nailing it I'm nailing it guys
I'm nailing it
run
now
[Music]
okay god damn you [ __ ] god oh my god
they're so stupid there's no difference
to say that that was supposed to be a
mash and I know there's a tiny visual
difference in the button but oh my god
if you're not ready for it what are you
supposed to do are you [ __ ] ki just
when I think this game can't get more
douchey it just gets more douchey that's
so so stupid okay well that's not right
what the [ __ ] I don't know why the
characters are wrong but okay the effect
will probably be the same everyone just
ignore the fact that this is super weird
[Music]
get out get out of there yeah okay sure
and I'm ready for it this time I'm ready
as Sponge Bob says who knows a lot about
water and oceans I'm ready I don't care
if it's different people at this point I
will not die to [ __ ] a ghost
I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready there we
go it's a mashed there's nothing nothing
indicating that's a match ok d ok
alright we did it guys
weirdly have different people other
Yogi's oh that was real go out there was
a real Grouch what did you I'm so
grumbled
I'm very here let's get the hell out of
here let's get the hell out of here I'm
very very very grumbled but it's all
good it's all good baby so good baby
it's so good because at the end of the
day I ain't gonna let anyone die oh hey
we're how are you guys doing why are you
there wait what happened wait what
[Music]
oh you are kidding me oh you're kidding
me that was the last or you are you're
kidding me
that was the last thing period
[Music]
thank you I'm in the gorge
are you outside oh that was cold he
wanted the cold that's what this was
about
manchurian gold that turned out to be
quite a bit different than we expected
you know just keep going over it and
over it
and it doesn't make any sense
and I know what I saw I just don't
believe in
whatever it was I saw I saw Alec listen
Alex with
what else
you look just like Alex he was sneering
at me why is the audio all weird it's
like the audio is moving Vickie Ridge
kids
wow thanks Flis so is anybody else if
you like knocking back frosty this guy
you alcoholic barring updated oh yeah we
found the ring
well you know if a god it's all good
there's already a ring on your finger
that's weird
is it happy ending it's happy I'm happy
about this I'm pushing all the bad
energy out of my body hua hua hee hoo
hee hoo wah
so what I'm led to believe is the
painting that we found at the end there
oh hi
you talked to me congratulations all
your charges are still breathing and
that's something I suppose you suppose I
suppose when the curtain falls you're
either ready for it or you're not it's
all about decisions isn't it decisions
made in a hurry
in a panic made with the heart instead
of the head or vice versa sometimes
those decisions take a long time to have
repercussions but there are
repercussions there are always
repercussions
[Music]
till we meet again maybe in little hope
maybe somewhere else but be certain we
will meet again uh-huh inevitable thanks
for standing where the credits are there
was a perfectly nice framing over on the
right side and yet where you're standing
yeah all right as is usual for these
credits sequence I have to wait until
the end to see if there's a secret that
you would not get unless you if you
skipped so I'm going to wait okay here
we are I probably could have skipped but
I like to wait that's how I do I'm an
obstinate son-of-a-bitch there was ever
something to write on my tombstone
obstinate son hey you're alive
well that can't be good there's anything
we need to do it's add more soldiers and
guns to this mix how do they have gas
masks they're so smart
no they don't taste covers right because
they didn't want to pay to make more
than so I guess we got a real-life
[ __ ] here uh-huh
well what the hell is this
[Music]
oh hi Danny hey how you doing man those
soldiers should add guns that's
something I suppose going it alone
consider all the permutations right okay
all right so this game is an anthology
the reason it's much shorter than until
dawn is because it's supposed to what I
imagined release episodes like the next
thing was probably gonna be called
little hope this one's called man of
Madonn but the whole thing is called the
something-something anthologies I don't
even know but man damn here's my
thoughts this game wasn't good this
story was pretty okay
the scares were few and far between but
I'm talking about the game itself the
actual playing that you do was not very
fun number one because it entirely
relied on QuickTime events and the gut
reaction making decisions of and then
living the consequences thereof those
decisions which on its surface is fine
it is fine and I get that you're
supposed to play through it once and
then that's it but that's not how I
enjoy game now what I'm saying as the
experience of man of Madden was pretty
okay I appreciate the ambition of what
it tries to do but it seems weird
considering we already have something to
compare it to which is until dawn and
the experience of mana Madden even
though it's coming four years after the
fact is less than until dawn was until
dawn even though it had those same kind
of [ __ ] mechanics and admittedly the
decision that I made and I decided to
replay through the whole game was my own
fault and my own stupidity to trust a
voice in the cellar my decisions that I
made that led to my demise in these ones
were all out of my control I was okay
with making the decisions that led to
these events but every death I had was
because I failed a QuickTime event it
had nothing to do with the decisions I
made there in and of course one could
argue that the other decisions that I
made prior to that could have
led to a different scenario where the
QuickTime event that I would have
experienced would not have been the
sleet but the clues that it had to the
future had very little and or nothing to
do with the deaths that I caused so
we're in the until dawn game had a lot
of butterfly effect things that you
could see the crux of the event and it
wasn't entirely clear what you needed to
do but at least the event itself was
more obvious as to what was necessary
who survived that situation in this one
it was not I tried to use my inference
in certain occasions to be like oh I
know that's Brad I don't want to stab
bread and I was correct in that
assumption I know for a fact if I had
tried to stab Brad I would have killed
Brad but then I failed the QuickTime
event afterwards because of number one
there was an issue with sticky keys the
keyboard wasn't always connecting there
was that situation where if I'd look at
something and I click the button back
the keyboard suddenly wouldn't work
anymore it was a little unreliable and
the whole concept of WASD as the clues
I've been playing for first and shooters
and working with a keyboard all my life
I know WASD very well but if you ask me
to press D instantly that is not merely
gonna be as quick as if you asked me to
press write if you ask me to press write
often a press right like you wouldn't
believe I'm gonna press right and I
think the difference is when I played
until dawn it was meant to be
experienced on a controller because I
played it on the PlayStation 4 this is
his first time being ported over to PC
there's a lot of problems with it over
on PC and I think it's a factor of this
game was made for the PlayStation and
then ported over to the PC and the PC is
a subpar experience that is my guess
that is what I imagine and it is rather
shitty
that I turned to the debug mode to get
back to where I was but I felt like I
had to because it was so unfair of what
happened to me all that being said all
of my complaints are simply my
complaints and my complaints are my
complaints because I'm an obstinate
douchebag and if things don't go my way
I throw a temper tantrum that is just
who I am and I get that that doesn't
reflect poorly on the game just by my
own arguments
but my criticisms of the game their
force aren't dismissed entirely just
because I'm an obstinate douchebag
there are some legitimate criticisms to
be made about this game but I still
enjoyed what it was trying to do I
didn't entirely enjoy the overall
experience but what makes it even more
frustrating is I could see a world where
it was good I get frustrated the most in
my life when I see something that isn't
living up to its potential and I see a
lot of potential in this and I don't
know if it's entirely due to a bad pc
port there was a lot of like bugs and
weirdness in the game and I think that
has to do was just being like let's put
theirs on PC and there's a lot of issues
with that but that being said this is
the experience I had I would still
recommend this game for the specific
reason that I think it would be fun to
play with friends it would be fun to
play these modes where it says shared
story or movie night past the pad and
play the story together which makes a
lot of sense if you really think about
it like cuz this experience is more of a
movie than it is a game and this idea
behind a shared couch co-op experience I
am all about I love that idea I love it
a lot I think that's a really clever way
of doing things now whether or not the
game is actually more engaging and
interesting in that department really
depends like I'm not to say if I had to
do this all over again I would have
started even if I'm still playing by
myself I would have started movie night
because I think there was a lot of
elements where I didn't get to play
other characters and a lot of other
choices were just left out of my control
just because I didn't play with anybody
else so if you play this game play it
with co-op let me know what you think
about it because I think there's a lot
more enjoyment to be had out of it there
and for the love of God play it on a
controller and make sure your controller
works
don't play it on PC it's basically what
I'm saying the pc version of this is
very not fun anyway that was man of
madden I will still be playing the next
versions in this anthology I will
because like I said I enjoyed the idea
behind it there was a lot of
opportunities for really cool stuff to
happen and sometimes they took those
opportunity
other times they let me down in a big
way but that's how this game is
sometimes until dawn you know I made
some errors and I made some poor
decisions and I was able to live with a
lot of those decisions in fact I don't
think I even had everyone survive up
until the point where I decided to
replay through the whole game and yet I
kept going because I felt like I needed
to own up to those decisions fair a few
of the decisions in here did I feel like
I need to own up to and that's because
I'm an obstinate douchebag but anyway
that is all for this game if you want to
see until dawn check the link of the
description below where you can see the
entire playthrough and my mental
breakdown in about episode 10 or 11 I
can't remember which but thank you again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]